okay so I'm gonna need your sort of like
your help on this story actually
yesterday I was starting to work on
today's show researching some stories
putting some notes together and I
started getting emails and tweets
probably about ten or twelve in total
people linking me to the same video and
it's a video a supposedly leaked video
of Elizabeth Warren talking to Union
officials in a private meeting about
health care and the headline was Warren
bails on Medicare for all Warren aborts
Bernie's Medicare for all plan
devastating Warren cotton leaked video
distancing from Bernie's Medicare for
all plans so I was ready to come in
today and just crush Elizabeth Warren
for abandoning Medicare for all with no
specific alternative and yeah I was
ready to go and then I watched the video
and in the video I don't see Elizabeth
Warren do that I see in the video
Elizabeth Warren say that Medicare for
all is the cheapest way to get the best
care to the highest number of people
wait I thought what why how is that
possible I thought it was devastating
video of Elizabeth Warren abandoning
Medicare for all I was ready to just say
look at this terrible disgusting video
of Elizabeth Warren then I saw the video
and I don't understand where the
headlines are coming from so I need your
help today in figuring this out we're
gonna look at the video the first
question any time you hear about a
leaked video is was the video really
leaked a lot of things that are
supposedly leaked under the Trump
administration we later find out are
leaked by Trump officials because they
think that it's gonna look good for them
or whatever was this video really leaked
I don't know if you believe it was
leaked then you're probably predisposed
to assume that Elizabeth Warren says or
does something bad in it I don't know if
the video was leaked from the recording
it seems like someone is just sitting
right in front of Elizabeth Warren
recording to fit to the thing recording
the thing I don't know the answer to
that but let's listen to what Elizabeth
Warren says and again English is my
second language maybe there are some
grammatical or linguistic nuances here
that I'm not understanding where she
says that she's bailing on Medicare for
all I'm just not seeing it and I want to
make sure that I
understand this so let's look at clip
number one I'm gonna be if I can a
little more open textured about this one
the way I see it is we need to know what
the goal is and the goal has got to be
yeah we've got to be in a place where we
get coverage for everybody at the lowest
possible cost and the numbers are just
clearly that's medicare for all I the
Republicans put together a study to show
how expensive Medicare for all
what's gonna be you know they really
wanted to they wanted to show us and it
turned out was cheaper than any
alternative that anybody could come up
with because you cut out all the crazy
billing you cut out all of the fighting
with the insurance companies and you cut
out the twenty three billion dollars in
profits that the insurance companies
sucked out of the system just last year
alone and that doesn't even count what
they spent on CEO salaries remember
their basic business model taken as much
as you can of premiums and payout as
little as you can in health care
coverage saying no it's how they make
money so this is not sustainable over a
long period so we've got to figure out
that's where we're headed now how do we
get there and for me I think of it the
way I think of trade and as it matters
who's at the table I want to make sure
that the folks were at the table our
folks who don't have health care
coverage oh I make sure they of their
but also folks who do have health care
coverage okay so so far I hear Elizabeth
Warren talking up Medicare for all I
hear her talking about lower cost and
higher access and it's good and she
wants to be sure that unions who have
already negotiated health care for their
union members in many cases are part of
the conversation about what is going to
be done with healthcare so you if we
want to steal man the worst possible
interpretation of this
she may be alluding to
unions may be happy with what they have
of course most people are not in unions
but I'm not seeing anything there that
matches the headlines that I was seeing
so let's continue and again I was ready
for Elizabeth Warren's big abandonment
of Medicare for all I was ready to come
in here and go point by point destroying
her we were smelling blood at the David
Pakman show but I'm not seeing it in the
video let's look at clip number two for
those for a helmet is already part of
their compensation package then we got
to think about adjustments and the law
to make sure not just that out of the
goodness of their hearts that some
employers will make up the difference
but that that's part of the legal
structure for people who don't have any
coverage we've got to make sure that
they're represented about how fast we
can get them into the system so when I
hear people say well we'll do 55 50 45
what's great if you have health
insurance we got to find a way to get
people into Medicare for all as quickly
as we can so this is pretty
uncontroversial how do we get coverage
quickly to people she's pointing out
that if you phase in Medicare for all by
going from 65 as the age at which you
can get into it down to 60 down to 55
down to 50 that in practical terms
that's too slow for people who don't
have health care right now we need to do
something to get them health care more
quickly now again you could interpret
that as her saying we need to do a full
phasing of Medicare for all even faster
than has been proposed by some people or
on the other side you could interpret
that as we need something else in
addition to Medicare for all because
some people aren't going to be able to
get Medicare for all right away if it's
phased in over time but this is not
exactly devastating I'm just not seeing
it so now let's go to the next clip and
this is a part that she is absolutely
getting crushed for so it's not that I
have a plan that says we're going to do
this part and we're going to do this
part and then we're going to do this
part no instead my plan is we're going
to get to a table
like this we're gonna make sure
everybody gets represented we're gonna
understand the urgency of the moment to
get this salt with people who aren't
covered and get ourselves on a path
where everybody can get there and
everybody can get covered at the lowest
possible cost
that's what Medicare for all is all
about I hope that's a helpful answer
so people are crushing elizabeth warren
on this part because she says i don't
have a plan of doing this part and then
this part and then this part there's two
interpretations here one interpretation
is she has no plan right that would be
like the the harshest interpretation the
other interpretation and again i think
there's some linguistic ambiguity here
is she's saying i don't have a plan for
a sequential phase in i need to get
everybody who doesn't have health care
health care right away she is saying as
i hear it
medicare for all is what we are doing
but we need everyone at the table and
slowly phasing it in with different
lowering age requirements is too slow if
you have an acute need for health care
right now i'm gonna be totally honest i
don't really see what the controversy is
this to me is actually more strongly for
medicare for all than what i've seen her
say in the past which has been
problematic so even if you interpret
this in the least charitable way based
on my grasp of the English language she
seems to be saying she's open to things
other than medicare for all
continuing to exist in parallel with
medicare for all for example for people
who have healthcare negotiated through
their unions which is a very small
percentage of the country i think 8
percent of the country is in a union and
i my guess is that not that full eight
percent has guaranteed health care as a
result of being in that union who cares
i mean i think that from the beginning
i've said running on making private
insurance illegal is a mistake let the
market dictate what happens to private
insurance if you put in a really good
medicare for all plan if private
insurance is terrible compared to
medicare-for-all witch it likely would
be then people will get out of those
risk pools and that will make private
insurance even more expensive and that
will make more people get out of it and
the market will actually resolve that
issue pretty tightly so again I want
your help
I just don't seem to be understanding
we're in this Elizabeth Warren is
abandoning Medicare for all I'm hearing
her in much stronger terms that I've
heard over the last three to six months
from her three months I guess I would
say be in favor of Medicare for all
maybe my understanding of the English
language is just not up to par and maybe
that's where I'm missing this I want to
hear from you where is the big
abandonment